everybody welcome back to pivara I know
it's been a terrible amount of time
since I released the last episode and
I'll talk a bit more about that later in
this episode I have to admit I actually
did have to change my planning up a
little bit as well since I was planning
to make this the longest episode but
pretty much fate wanted that I had to
spend much more time on this project
than I ever conceived of which is you
know the standard but you know even
taking into consideration that things
take longer than you expect they take
longer than I expected it we're taking
longer than expected so yeah we're
running into issues basically but this
is according to the current planning
which will hopefully work out the second
the last episode in which we'll be
working on a lot of detailing throughout
the island the basic shape is there but
I wanted to get some extra elements in
most of which are actually the
propellers around the island which is
supposed to keep the island up I know we
only got two until now but I wanted to
support the rest as well and get some
systems in place too
somehow in some kind of fantasy be able
to move these things around the island
and rotate them and use them as a
ridiculous steering system for the onion
I know it makes no sense but we're
talking a floating steampunk console
here so I hope you don't mind too much
now the last episode I guess you're
wondering it sort of planned to be the
final detailing for the island really
getting the last gritty industrial
elements in not so much really shaping
anything or adding anything to the
island really just getting the final
touches in and basically it means I get
to put random stuff on the island
wherever I kind of hear what can work
but also finishing the rest of the
surroundings so actually getting some
sort of context to this entire island
now there's some bigger stuff that I
want to talk about though as I sort of
get into supporting the first tower here
and adding some details around that
because you know you're probably
wondering what's been the holdup about
for vara or my upload rate in general
and since I don't really want to make an
update video because I kind of feel like
that's just kind
noise pollution on my channel I'll try
to explain it as quickly and as easily
as I can in this video
I've just been really busy recently
without giving too many details doing an
internship somewhere far away but not
quite far away and for such a long time
that I was going to get an apartment
there I probably should have looking
back at it now because I spent 4 time
days but also traveling four hours a day
plus all kinds of other things which
means that I don't have much time left
for planet coaster which is one of the
reasons why my upload rate is so
extremely low lately but when it comes
to pivara in general I've let a lot of
other projects go before it and there's
there's a couple of problems that I'm
stuck with at the moment
one I've got too many projects going at
the same time I started all of them kind
of thinking I need more I started varam
because I didn't have a main on planet
coaster series but that just kind of
really got filled up by qawalli Beach
and Garuda both of which especially
turned out to take much more of my time
than I expected beforehand but also some
other stuff like Jaeger horn which I
probably shouldn't have spotted yet
looking back at it and then there's all
kinds of other stuff that I did in
between like I don't know appearing on
other people streams doing blended bro
coaster trying some other stuff in the
meantime it's hard to actually find time
to get to work on pivara again and
whenever I work on some certain project
it really just means that my other stuff
gets delayed by a lot more than I
would've wanted now another problem and
this is something that I've been wanting
to get off my chest for a very long time
and I just want to get it out because I
don't really believe in making YouTube a
fake happy marketable place is that I've
just generally been very tired of the
projects that I'm doing at the moment
you might very well recognize it it's
probably the the one symptom that leads
to many people starting new projects and
after working on it a little bit and
maybe halfway finishing it just
abandoning it and starting something new
I'm really going through that
pays as well at the moment where it's
more of a chore for me to work on these
projects than it is actually fun and a
lot of it really has just become work
and while that doesn't mean I don't want
to do it I think personally it made the
entire quality of what I make suffer in
the end and when I look back at some of
the things I made earlier I kind of feel
bad about the fact that I like them more
but also they feel so much more the
products of something fun and this is I
guess something that I wanted to give to
everybody watching as well
projects like Favara at the moment for
me are something that I feel really bad
about because even though I know that a
lot of people watch it and a lot of
people really enjoy the content it's
something content at the moment I don't
enjoy making and that's something I kind
of feel guilty about because it's
perhaps what planet coaster should be
about most and I see a lot of comments
from people also saying that these kinds
of idioms are demotivating in a sense
because they feel like they could never
build anything like this to which I
would like to say it's just a game in
the end and the most important thing is
to have fun and don't be like me because
it's actually a really bad example just
have fun in the game and do whatever you
feel like makes you feel like it's fun
and don't try to do something just
because you want to get it done and
that's that's my major mistake with
especially projects like these because
no matter how good other people might
think they look or how bad other people
might think they look the only real
opinion that matters about whatever you
build is whether you like it and whether
it's something that you enjoy building
and that's something that I'm not really
going through with the stuff that I'm
working on at the moment and I don't
want to end this on the sour note
whatsoever because I do want to finish
these things it's not that I'm
completely tired of planet coaster apart
from it I still love this game I'm just
having to go through the chore of
finding time and finding the rail to
actually finish these projects before I
hand onto things again that I have fun
doing but on until that time I'm I guess
to deter
and to finish these things even if I
don't like working on them and perhaps I
guess simultaneously my biggest mistake
and something I shouldn't do but
something I do want to do just get this
stuff out there but that means that I
don't know for me the quality isn't in
hi and my upload rate definitely suffers
so if you're that kind of person who
feels like you're watching this kind of
stuff and you don't know what to do with
this game and you - won't give up
just remember it's just a game and the
most important thing to have fun and not
be like me but yeah that's basically
that entire story the moral of the story
and guess is then I will try to finish
these things but afterwards hopefully
get some more more fun things but not
trying to take the game too seriously
and not trying to make everything too
much of a chore so um yeah to get back
to the topic at hand here which is
probably the worst the most awkward
transition I've ever had to do the stuff
that I'm doing at the moment is trying
to connect these weird little parts of
the track to the rest of the island and
it takes all doing some custom supports
but also adding those weird machines
everywhere and just combining all the
different objects into weird steampunky
objects to try and connect the tracks to
the rest of the island a problem with
these kinds of strikes words that they
are very far away from the rest of the
island em it was really no way to kind
of get to supporting these without
building ridiculous machinery out of the
island itself so there's a bunch of
things taking out also something to I
guess keep in mind is that the island is
very small it's a very narrow strip of
land so a lot of it has to be built from
the outside to the kind of support
that's weaving track here so really I'm
just putting random objects together and
seeing how well they work although for a
few things I've definitely tested them
and then work
super well sometimes confusing me while
such as the the kennel eaters which have
become many rings on these different
machines you might notice a lot of those
pieces are cookies or whatever the names
of those different items are not sure I
might look that up very quickly but yeah
those there's lots of different
interesting objects in there that you
wouldn't really otherwise expect you'd
want to actually build machinery out of
and that's still one of my favorite
parts of doing something like this not
just to thank then you can completely
ignore realism and do some crazy things
but just the way that you can combine
objects together in this in this game to
make something they're not all supposed
to be is something that I still love
about it all right
a lot of the machinery pieces that I
used for the round sections particularly
are the malted biscuits yes that's the
convention the malted biscuits which
actually work out quite well they have
that sort of beige texture to it
I guess the the jammy biscuits work out
as well you can kind of tell that this
game is made by British people and also
there's there are some of those
chocolate cups as well which I'm not
sure they kind of look like Reese's Cups
but maybe I'm too American or to
Europeans even getting what they look
like okay I have to look this up right
now but basically we've got all sorts of
candies in there so there's some
interesting machinery going on some of
the other pieces include some of the
other fountain pieces or whatever you'd
really call them there's some of those
statues and centerpiece elements that
you can build all kinds of things out of
oh yeah they do look my Reese's butter
butter cups I get I guess they're peanut
butter cups which it's something that
still confuses me seriously those I've
had them once and I still don't
understand how Americans like that stuff
but anyway without getting too
stereotypical here that's basically what
a lot of stuff is build out of now I
wanted to make a quick terrible segue
into doing the bottom of the island here
and what is arguably the worst of ideas
actually have to laugh but this kind of
it's just the very effect that I decided
to actually go through it this is
something that still baffles myself as
well I've been thinking about the
underside of the island for ever since I
started this project because it's
something that's quite challenging you
oiss
it's one of the challenges actually I
think of building and floating whatever
you normally don't really have to worry
about what the things that you built
look like from the underside because you
build them about the ground so don't
really see that side but with the
floating island there's this big lower
part of the build that you see but it's
really hard to do anything with it
especially because building upside down
is a bit tricky but also you don't want
to get the focus there but I also didn't
want to make it just look like a
floating simple rock I wanted to do
something with it and whether I wanted
to keep this shape or important to make
an airship out of the entire build I
really wasn't sure so the other unit I
stuck with and I know that lengths have
become kind of a meme on my channel at
this point this is maybe a worst thing
that I've ever done but the idea that I
spoke with was putting planks alongside
the entire underside of the island I
know this doesn't do very well for my
arguments that have begun if you're kind
of tired with building this stuff and
planet coaster but this is actually kind
of amusing I don't know why there was
something really funny about putting
hundreds of blanks on the bottom of a
floating island I was about the last
thing I ever saw myself doing but now
that I'm doing it it kind of makes sense
in a way but yeah this is one big layer
of coating on the other side of the
island to give it that kind of
otherworldly atmosphere to it and also
just get rid of that rocky texture
because I was in kind of fan of having a
huge intricate steampunk castle on top
of floating island and just leaving the
floating island be normal it has to be
something weird and something mechanical
steampunky so every deep reddish brown
set of planks alongside the entire
underside felt like something that would
more or less fit the island and
hopefully this kind of texture with all
of the different planks sort of going
alongside
Island in terms of rotation helps to
give the island that sort of fantasy
quality to it and make it seem a bit
weirder because in the end this is this
is also like I think I said in some of
the earlier episodes it's really just a
license to go crazy and do some stuff
that you'd normally not even want to
think about it so now we're putting
planks on the other side of this entire
island and if you're worrying about the
time lapse I I did got quite a lot of
time lapse of putting planks down here
out as well I didn't even blank out the
entire island yet I still I still have
to muster up the energy to actually
through some of the remaining parts but
yeah it was actually pretty funny to do
all of this it's also getting
progressively harder to actually put
commentary over it because it's doing
one single thing the entire time you're
worrying about my mental sanity by the
way at this point I was just in a voice
call with people having been Turing and
stuff in fact I was in the ladies on a
stream at the time that might also be
why I was saying incredibly stupid
things in the stream I apologize I say
stupid things when I record planning
coaster and that's why I usually don't
want to record planet coaster whenever
I'm even being remotely social it turns
out bad both for my social skills and
for my planet coaster skills but in this
sense you know I just had to place
blanks so it was more or less fine
anyway with that weird little sidestep
out of the way what is the point of
things that I wanted to get to was
putting some more you call these things
again I know I've said it at the
beginning of the episode yeah some more
of these propeller things at the side of
the island and give them their own
little moving around spaces which still
doesn't make much sense but it looks
pretty cool so I figured I would just go
for it the inspiration for the shape of
these things believe it or not the
spaceship from 2001 a Space Odyssey I
figured that would kind of fit their big
long sticks and but instead of having a
huge bowl at the end they have this
teller and I think it kind of works at
least they're quite pointy and add a bit
of depth to the entire building as well
I wasn't quite feeling like there were
enough towers in the building I wanted
more Howry pointing things on the
building but I didn't quite want to make
more towers because that would just
become very ridiculous and disney-like
so instead we're putting some some
propeller towers on the side here which
doesn't make it much better but it's a
bit crazier and weird so that works out
quite well and of course and this is one
of my main reasons still an important
philosophy in steampunk is that the
machinery that you see shouldn't just be
gears that are slapped onto everything
to make it look steampunk in fact using
these little gears as you can to make
something like steampunk is something
that I always admire but all of the
machinery that you'd see should
hopefully have some kind of function and
some kind of purpose in the entire build
that you see so adding these kinds of
propeller towers and adding all kinds of
moving parts around that might not be
great from a structural sense and I'm
sure that there might be some engineers
more engineering students watching it
and very mad at me but at least it's
it's a good way to add moving parts and
all kinds of machinery in a sense that
actually you know with a very big
suspension of disbelief some kind of
steampunk sense speaking of steam I
didn't want to add some chimneys as well
get some smoke coming out of that maybe
we'll get to some steam again as well
just to get some extra particles in here
make everything like a bit more alive
and interesting and the same kind of
goes for those random little details I'm
a big fan of these chains just because
they really fit the atmosphere but they
also allow you to put all kinds of
random details in small mixing crannies
but I also really like those cables and
other things that now you can use to
make things look a little bit dirty make
it look like everything just kind of
assembled in this haywire way instead of
all neatly organized and put away like
we do it nowadays which is kind of
interesting one of the one of the things
about the steampunk theme I tend to see
in
all of the machinery and all of the
moving clients and everything is very
visible it's very much out there it's a
part of the charm and the look of the
theme whereas nowadays everything tends
to be very much in a way look at a
smartphone and all the important bits
are invisible the only thing you see is
really just a flat piece of whatever
material it's made of and you see that
with a lot of the stuff that we have
nowadays but with steampunk everything
that is mechanical and moves around and
is a part of the living breathing
machine is something that is visible as
well which is something that I think is
very interesting about it not that I
advocate putting the inside of your
mobile phone outside but it's something
that I always thought is quite
interesting about this game punk theme
and maybe what it gets part of its charm
for as well so on the other side anyway
we have this other propeller tower as
well it's not quite as big and I wanted
to find some other ways of actually
putting this alongside the side of the
building so we've got some separate
rails on one side which doesn't make
much sense I still should support it
from the other side but we'll see about
how that's going to work at some point
in the future to be honest I'm not
really too concerned about how this
works properly but in any case we've got
all kinds of moving policies so that's
pretty cool now that's been it for this
episode of four fara so I would like to
thank you guys so much for watching
sorry about my huge monologue of being
tired of this game I definitely am NOT
I'm just trying to wrap up all of my
current stuff and get myself together
and get my [ __ ] together which I'm being
terrible at so I just wanted to vent
that but hopefully we'll be fine in the
end M is what will be finished and
there's a core project to look back at
and some more fun projects to start with
and that's something that I'm really
looking forward to doing since a very
long time so yeah I hope you guys
enjoyed and I'll see you in the next
episode
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]